nicolae ceausescu et sa femme elena ont
donc été arrêtés par l'armée à 70 km au
nord-ouest de bucarest
dès ce matin il avait fui en hélicoptère
puis se sentant pour chasser il avait
changé de moyens de transport il avait
tenté de s'enfuir en voiture cette fois
voici cette course pathétique d'un
dictateur en fuite à travers son pays
corinne pertuis nicolas ceausescu a fui
en hélicoptère de bucarest
ils tentent de partir pour la chine le
comité de salut national qui vient de
prendre le pouvoir
'l'annonce à la foule dans un meeting
improvisé la traque du dictateur va
durer une partie de la journée les
dépêches des agences de noront des
informations contradictoires
12h45 nicolae ceausescu et sa femme
d'école du palais présidentiel puis se
pose à l'aéroport de titou aussitôt de
hauts responsables militaires donne
l'ordre à l'armée de se saisir de
l'ancien dictateur sur le point d'être
attrapé il échappe
c'est alors en voiture que le couple
présidentiel et plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs tentent de fuir
14h30 enfin la radio annonce
l'arrestation de nicolas tièche est
secoué de sa femme attire gaulliste et
c'est à dire environ 70 km au nord-ouest
de bucarest à peine 40 minutes après une
dépêche annonce l'arrestation de nigou
ceausescu leur fils assis bout la ville
dont il était le chef